it was a decision made long before the
church discussion was ever under
consideration
when the president gives an order people
act it's not as if he's walked through
each and every detail of
how a plan goes about he says i want to
go to the church
he goes to the church and everyone
executes the plan in the order that the
president puts into place so the
president is absolutely right in what he
said
so was the plan still for president
trump to walk out there even if the
protesters
were still there you know i'm not aware
of the determinations that secret
service had as they arranged for the
president to walk out there but i would
just note again
that the decision to expand the
perimeter was a decision made in the
morning by attorney general barr
okay just one question about uh the
coronavirus because we're still in the
middle of a pandemic
uh dr fauci he said in an interview on
monday that his
contact with president trump had
dramatically decreased and so had the
the frequency
of the coronavirus task force meetings
is that accurate
and if so why there was a coronavirus
task force briefing just
yesterday we are constantly as an
administration monitoring the
coronavirus to protect the safety and
well-being of the american people
um right now we all saw that church burn
we all saw some of the violence in the
streets and the president has had
several meeting after meeting with a.g
barr
secretary esper general milley to make
sure that our streets are peaceful and
under control while also monitoring
the coronavirus and and what we're
seeing develop there
mario thanks kylie i'm quite confused i
mean
if the protests were were peaceful on
monday
why did you all clear the area and whose
decision was to clear it
later in the day if attorney general bar
wanted it clear earlier in the day
why did it take so long for it to be
cleared yeah you know he ordered it to
be cleared monday morning it didn't
happen when he arrived so
he immediately instructed the officers
to ensure that it was moved back
a block as we all saw sunday night it
was not a peaceful protest it was in
fact a riot with a church
burning in washington dc the president
made sure that washington d.c was secure
monday night
and part of that involved moving the
perimeter back to ensure that st
john's church was protected but that was
a that's a
quite a gap between the morning and then
the evening when you all walked over
there
why was there such a gap look again
that's a a question for
a.g bar who made the order to question
for the officers who were on the ground
at time why that wasn't deployed right
away but
when a.g bar came to the white house i
think it was early afternoon he noticed
that it hadn't been cleared gave the
order for it to be cleared
and that action took place
why did the president feel it was
important to go walk over there through
the park into the church
it was extremely important look the
president wanted to send a very
powerful message that we will not be
overcome
by looting by rioting by burning this is
not what defines
america and going and standing by saint
john's church was a very
important moment and i would note that
through all of time
we've seen presidents and leaders across
the world who have had leadership
moments and very powerful symbols that
were important for a nation to see at
any given time to show a message of
resilience and determination like
churchill we saw him inspecting the
bombing damage it's in a powerful
message of leadership to the british
people and george w bush
throwing out the ceremonial first pitch
after 9 11 and jimmy carter
putting on a sweater to encourage energy
savings and george h.w bush signing
the americans with disabilities act
flanked by two disabled americans and
for this president
it was powerful and important to send a
message that the writers the looters the
anarchists they will not
prevail that burning churches are not
what america is about
and that moment holding the bible up is
something that has been widely hailed by
franklin graham and others
and it was a very important symbol for
the american people to see that we will
get through this
through unity and through
the faith you said he had the results of
his physical
we know that he did part of the physical
late last year i think it was when did
he have the rest of it done
i'm not aware of an exact date um i will
ask
dr connelly for you on that but i i know
it was fairly recently
yes um i will go to berets
thanks uh the white house has spent a
lot of time talking about
uh how the protests have taken place and
how people
are protesting or shouldn't be
processing but what is the white house
doing to address the underlying causes
that have led to these protests the
president's done a lot the president
expedited
the review the fbi review of the george
floyd case
he swiftly ensured there was a civil
rights investigation
into george floyd's death ahmed arbory
there's an
another investigation there on the part
of doj he's recognized what an injustice
this was
innumerable times including in his
national remarks
that he gave on saturday um so this
president had the president has done
everything in his power to send
a powerful message that these injustices
will not be tolerated
have they reached out to any of these
protesters to try and start a dialogue
about specific reforms they'd like to
see
or does the president plan to do that
moving forward look the president
has looked at some various not
legislative necessarily but
tools that we could use to ensure that
law enforcement uses the appropriate
level of force no discussions or
announcements there on that front
but i will say that we're taking a hard
look at this but that the president
recognizes that our
police officers are valiant heroes the
vast majority are good
hard-working people who love this
country and who love the american
citizenry that they protect
thanks kaley former deputy attorney
general rod rosenstein testified today
on the hill
that uh he didn't read the bizarre
applications and he didn't even prepare
the scope memo that started the mueller
probe
given that rosenstein appears to be
deeply involved in uh crossfire kirkland
in that
he actually picked fbi director
christopher wray
isn't it time that the trump
administration appoints someone else
other than rape or fbi director look i
have no announcements on that front but
what i will say with regard to the
rosenstein testimony is he said
um there was no there there and he now
agrees with that text by peter strzok
who
um you know obviously had no information
that of russian collusion but
nevertheless
um strung us through this investigation
and you have rosenstein who again it's
quite befuddling said he
wouldn't have signed off on the carter
page fisa warrant that has his name on
it his name's on
signed on a fisa warrant to spy on the
trump campaign uh that he wouldn't have
signed off on that not only that he
wasn't sure that he read every page of
it
it's a pretty grave thing to spy on an
american citizen to violate their fourth
amendment rights to not have a basis to
do so and to rely on a russian dossier
full of lies as the justification
um so it's really astonishing to hear
from him that he's not sure he read
every page
of that warrant but i suppose it's
encouraging to hear with his
2020 hindsight that he wouldn't have
signed off on it though i'm sure that's
of no card
no comfort to carter page well the
president has expressed his
disappointment in ring in the past so
where does he stand now does he have
confidence in ray today
at this moment the president as the fbi
director much like the secretary of
defense is the fbi director is the
secretary of defense if the president
decides he no longer has confidence you
guys will be the first to know
one more on new york if it's okay um so
yesterday
new york governor cuomo made a pretty
big statement saying that he
he might relieve de blasio mayor de
blasio of his duties
uh has there been any talk with governor
cuomo about sending in the national
guard troops to new york or is there any
plan right now to send national guard to
new york
the president will do whatever is
necessary to protect america's streets
he has made that clear and he has
several tools that is one of them
sending in the national guard he does
have the ability to federalize the
national guard should he choose
to do that but i would note and i'm very
glad you brought up new york
the very clear-cut cases of d.c and new
york
d.c was in chaos on sunday night when
you saw the burning of the church
when mayor bowser did not set the curfew
as she had it at 11 p.m the president
said this is unacceptable he's always
preferred devolving to the states
they have the police power it's their
responsibility to protect the streets
but when the president saw that on
sunday night
he took action immediately he surged
the national guard encouraged states to
accept their national guard
he went on and on with several various
actions he gave a very powerful speech
saying if you don't act
i will he noted that the military would
be on hand should it be necessary
his bold action his swift action made dc
a much different story monday night and
contrasting the images of new york
or excuse me dc on monday night in new
york on monday night where there was a
rampant
looting where we saw macy's department
store looted coach store looted
violence in the streets new york acted
in a way that was inappropriate they
didn't deploy the national guard they
set an 11 pm curfew even after they saw
the disastrous results of mayor bowser's
11 pm curfew and the president said i
will call antifa a domestic terrorist
group
what was new york doing new york was
arresting people on burglary charges and
then releasing 500 individuals after
they had arrested them so
the weak need policies of new york stand
in stark contrast
to the law and order policies of this
president that has succeeded in securing
this city
um as we've seen the last two nights um
next so go to lachlan
thank you putting aside the conduct of
individual officers
does the president believe that there's
a systemic bias
in american law enforcement against
african americans
the president believes that there are
injustices and he has pointed them out
and he has not hesitated in pointing out
injustices going back to his time as a
primary candidate
when he called sandra bland and the use
of force against her in the video that
we all saw
terrible he did not hesitate when he saw
the video of george floyd
he was really upset by that video as i
noted
he also we've got the civil rights
investigation into ahmed arbury he
points out injustices but he also notes
this that
our police officers are good people i've
seen them out there on the streets
protecting people i've played the videos
for you
of the police embracing protesters
standing with the protesters
they're good hard-working people they
protect our streets
that is what law enforcement is about um
and
but at the same time the president will
note and he will call out injustices and
this is a president who's
not hesitated in doing that when the
time was right
but does he believe that the problem is
systemic and endemic to american law
enforcement
the president believes there are some
examples of injustices he calls them out
this is a president who when democrats
for so many years talked about criminal
justice
reform and the disparities on the racial
disparities in sentencing
it didn't president obama didn't do that
guess who fixed that it was president
trump with the first step
act who engaged in sentencing reform and
who really rectified some of the
disparities we saw there so
you know i think democrats others
republicans should hail this president
for calling out injustices when he sees
them either in a case-by-case basis or
in the form of the first step act where
he noted
the disparity and sentencing reforms um
josh there's been a number of
explanations on the clearing the part
one that there was an attempt to
enforce curfew another that was violent
protesters from the park police
doj saying that it was previously uh
going to be done anyway
can you explain to us what the reason
from the white house's perspective was
to play in the park
why the white house wanted it done so it
wasn't the white house as i said it was
a.g barr who expanded the
it was a g bar who said the perimeter
needed to be expanded one block each way
because we were not going to see the
church burn another night
i've already gone through a meticulous
detail with my friend jim here
um how it came about that that perimeter
was eventually moved and i'm not going
to
repeat myself again that would have been
done anyway even if it would not have
been violent protesters that would have
happened
no there were three announcements so if
the protesters had remained peaceful and
had moved the perimeter as they were
instructed to do not one not two but
three times be a loud speaker
it would have looked different but when
bricks are thrown rest assured
officers will protect themselves
today that he went uh down to the
basement to
inspect it uh over the weekend can you
what was the
point of the inspection what was he
looking for look i won't go further than
what the president has said because
those are security matters and i won't
engage on that kind of
um discussion yesterday so going back to
rosenstein uh what what is the
president's response to
the fact that rosenstein neither
rosenstein nor
christopher ray seemed willing to take
responsibility for
the illegal wiretapping that took place
on the trump campaign i also have a
question on
yeah i would say look the president is
dismayed this happened to the
president's campaign a campaign
a republican campaign was spied on
by a democratic presidency a democratic
administration
based on a dossier dossier paid for by
his opponent hillary clinton and the dnc
this is absolutely extraordinary it is
the biggest political scandal
that we've seen and the lack of
journalistic curiosity on this front
is appalling when you have multiple
instances of people who are saying
one thing under oath from the obama
administration and saying another thing
in public that they had direct evidence
of russian collusion i mean that's
extraordinary adam schiff i've got
direct
evidence when in fact we know there was
none in the mueller report
after spending millions of taxpayer
dollars totally and completely
exonerated president trump it was a
travesty
and we hope to get to the bottom of this
because it should never be done
again in american politics to any
president of either political party
secretary esper this morning said that
he opposes it the last time it was used
was 1992
um if how close is the white house to
actually using
the insurrection act is that a last
resort measure or is this a real
possibility at this moment well if
you've noticed the president has
been going down a line of progression
and the first
point was allow governors to do their
job
allow mayors like bill de blasio to do
their job the police power
which is embedded in the 10th amendment
of this constitution that's how this
country is supposed to work
governor cuomo is supposed to ensure
that his state is protected mayor de
blasio
is supposed to ensure that new york city
is protected they failed at their job
there was looting
all across new york city there were
fires burning here in dc
when mayor bowser was in control so this
president on monday took definitive
action
with that speech saying if necessary the
military is here
you must search the national guard he
took action
and he shored up and made sure that dc
remained peaceful
um so this president will has has gone
and said the national guard is the next
step
um that seemed to be working here in new
york in d.c we'll see if it continues to
work
but rest assured he has the sole
authority to invoke the insurrection act
and if necessary he will do so to
protect american citizens
um one thing i really want to note just
and i think it's so important to go back
to this because i haven't seen a ton of
coverage of it
other than um in a few places and i
started
the briefing with this and it's
important i just want to circle back
and note captain david dorn who lost his
life in st
louis um and he was killed by a looter
he served 38 years in the st
louis police department his wife ann as
a sergeant with the saint louis
metropolitan police department he is a
hero
i also want to note because there have
been 45
officers lost in the line of duty this
year and my heart breaks for them and as
a new mom myself my heart particularly
breaks for
two women in particular who i was
reading about their stories today
officer brianne
leith of the indianapolis police
department on april 9
2020 she was shot and killed she
survived by her three-year-old son her
sister and her parents
she was a national guard veteran and my
heart breaks for the family of officer
leith
and officer tiffany victoria enriquez of
the honolulu police department on
january 19 2020. officer enriquez was
shot
and killed as well leaving three
daughters one grandson and she was a u.s
air force reserve
veteran these are our heroes thank you
so much to our officers who are
protecting our streets
many have been shot some have been
killed it's a travesty
and let us stand with law enforcement
and recognize the huge contribution that
they have made to our society
and continue to do so each and every day
thank you so much guys
i don't